[Musica]
[Applauso]
che cos'è il silenzio il silenzio è uno
spazio emotivo dove noi ci immergiamo
ripetiamo e cerchiamo il significato
delle cose
sono una ragazza sorda sorda dalla
nascita e adesso porto gli impianti
cocleari fino a 12 anni ho portato gli
apparecchi acustici
poi mi è stato consigliato di fare
intervento proprio qui a reggio emilia
ed è proprio qui che sono rinato ed ho
conosciuto i suoni della vita ma video
oggi è una cosa che silenzio hanno
insegnato una cosa importante cioè
quello di prendermi cura del mio difetto
infatti lo vedo come una forma di
bellezza come un pregio ma soprattutto
come un segno del destino
ed è per questo che dico che silenzio è
veramente il mio maestro perché mi ha
rivelato il vero significato della
bellezza la bellezza è un concetto
ognuno può interpretarlo come vuole
infatti ricercatori studiosi artisti
hanno cercato di dare una risposta
concreta
marotta non esiste secondo me la
bellezza è un viaggio un'esperienza un
viaggio che ci porta verso la scoperta
in questo mondo il mondo nelle emozioni
esiste la bellezza estetica la troviamo
in arte architettura e la pittura nella
musica nella poesia esiste la bellezza
epica la troviamo nella nostra vita la
vita di tutti i giorni negli sguardi di
un bambino nelle speranze dei sogni
nella bellezza dell'amore che lega la
nonna con la nipote nel rogo di un
anziano che rappresentano la saggezza e
noi ragazzi abbiamo tanto da imparare
dai bambini e dagli anziani
mi prendo cura della bellezza
architettonica attraverso questo
strumento
i due non vengo da un paesino vicino
palermo e si chiama pollina tutto è
partito da questa meravigliosa città che
è mio sole il mio punto di riferimento
che mi ha fatto capire tante cose
tutto è partito da questa giornata
d'inverno così da mente fredda e doveva
visitare una chiesa si chiama cappella
palatina che si trova a palazzo dei
normanni sono entrata in questa chiesa e
il premio d'inverno era completamente
sparito ho sentito un calore che mi ha a
volta che mi ha abbracciata in qualcosa
di inaspettato non era solo il calore
dell'architettura e della città ma era
il calore di dio e lì ho capito che
dovevo seguire i miei sogni
uno di questi è naturalmente i disegni
questa magica parola disegnare deriva
dal latino designare composta dalla
particella boe e della parola si nun che
significa assen è un elemento così
piccolo ma ricco di esplosività decide a
tante informazioni è costituito da due
elementi il significato e significante e
significato e con espressione di
contenuto che è interpretato dalla
nostra mente il significante con
l'espressione fisica interpretata dagli
organi di senso possiamo dirgli che
disegno non è altro che un insieme di
segni emozionanti vibranti che formano
un'unità ma come ti disegna
l'architettura naturalmente viaggiano
con gli occhi con la mente ma
soprattutto col cuore e tutto parte
dall'osservazione la sua vita mi ha
portato a questo a guardare i dettagli a
guardare le piccole cose e quindi ho un
osservazione molto più sviluppato è un
osservazione attenta a cui una
penetrante e poi interpretare
l'architettura attraverso la tecnica è
infine rilevare quegli elementi
architettonici che definiscono
l'architettura
molto spesso disegno viene visto come lo
strumento il progetto marotta ha un
concetto motto più profondo è quel
legame tra pensiero e la mamma e
conoscenza narrazione di storie di
persone ricerca di gomme
vi faccio vedere questi miei lavori a
sinistra questo spesso ho realizzato da
vivono il colosseo dove c'è il ritardo
di questi due strumenti il taccuino
nella sua sposa la penna la propria così
do mantica
la coppia più romantica che io conosca
non ne dicano mai
è incredibile a destra la basilica di
santa maria la salute dove potete vedere
è molto più dettagliato perché dettaglio
secondo me è l'emblema della bellezza
perché ci insegna ad amare le piccole
cose cin tenne a conoscere la verità a
sinistra una serie di schizzi di
architettura maggiormente barocca
realizzato il contratto libero fluido
senta rigore ordine ascoltando la musica
jazz si è barocco e jazz è privo di horn
è un caos ordinario di emozioni e quindi
questo intreccio di vicende e musica
escono fuori queste forme che suscitano
stupore meraviglia a destra
l'interpretazione dell'architettura si
dice che gli orti signor specchio
dell'anima io dico che l'architettura è
lo specchio dell'anima dell'architetto
del disegnatore un'interessante tecnica
del negativo invece di usare il nero su
bianco cioè bianco su nero cioè
veramente carico di espressività tra
l'altro santa maria del fiore e la
cooper brunelleschi sono oggetto di
studio di tanti miei disegni perché è
veramente l'emblema dell'innovazione
dove la tecnica e la bellezza si può a
destra
abbiamo colto mio laboratori dove voglio
far vedere che è importante sperimentare
perché ci porta verso tanto e strane
queste rappresentano le più belle
esperienze della mia vita
grazie al messina di camerino ho avuto
l'onore di disegnare per papà francesco
in visita al camerino e poi questo
murales
come potete vedere che si trova
all'interno dell'università
si tratta del palazzo ducale che
purtroppo attualmente inagibile a causa
terremoto del 2016 ragazzi perché
disegno l'architettura perché sono
terribilmente affascinata da questa
forza silenziosa
c'è una sintonia tra me e l'architettura
una forza che mi racconta la cultura la
storia la bellezza una forza che mi ha
aperto gli occhi
un altro mio sogno e design e progettare
il mont ele persone e futuro per
migliorare futuro cos'è il futuro dove
stiamo andando
a cosa ci porta il futuro siamo noi il
futuro è già qui siamo noi perché
c'erano delle figure poliedriche
multidisciplinari conosciamo tante
discipline e ci può portare alla
progettazione perfetta di prodotti
sistemi architetture una di queste
strane questo disegno e tecnologia
queste due discipline possono andare
d'accordo
assolutamente si sono spesso
contrastanti lì dicono fanno casino all
interno ma possono andare d'accordo
attraverso queste esperienze immersive
ratta mentata tratta abituare
videomapping spazi messi vi sembra delle
esperienze che hanno lo scopo di
immergere di avvolgere e coinvolgere
l'utente che fa vedere
l'architettura disegnata in un modo
completamente nuovo
questa è l'esempio è un progetto
realizzato con l'universita di camerino
un video mapping per la chiesa di
sant'agostino
di amatrice e interattivo attraverso un
dispositivo che riesce a rilevare
gestualità della mano
sono stata la matrice perché non potevo
fare un progetto senza conoscere ho
conosciuto il cuore degli amatriciane e
della città ma veramente è c'è una corsa
che li lega la memoria la memoria una
cosa così preziosa perché nel suo
silenzio ci ricordiamo di persone
momenti e naturalmente di architettura
la particolarità di questo video mapping
e che invece di usare video immagini che
normalmente si usano ho usato dai
disegni realizzati a mano che hanno lo
scopo non solo di vestire l'architettura
ma quello di conferire la giusta anno di
colmare quel vuoto e naturalmente di
scuotere il cuore delle persone
ma cosa serve disegno oggi se papa ci
pensa ne serve a proiettate le nostre
idee su carta accoglie la modellazione
parametrica che oggi ci offre che ha
come chiave il numero e dal numero
nascono delle geometrie complesse
sa cosa mi ha portato a riscoprire
un'altra bellezza la natura
noi abbiamo dimenticato una natura
abbiamo dimenticato che noi siamo natura
e io ho capito attraverso questa
disciplina che si chiama biomimesi
l'abbia mimesi consiste nel riprodurre
idee soluzioni processi del mondo
naturale per trasferire nel mondo atp
già ne esistono due ricerca top down and
bottom up topdown significa dall'alto
verso il basso è una ricerca e faceva
noi progettisti che parte dall'esigenza
artificiale fino alla risposta naturale
bottom up è una ricerca che fanno i
ricercatori biologi che parte da basso
l'ump dallo studio nella natura fino
alla sua applicazione attività
mi ha portato alla progettazione di
questa struttura si tratta di una tenda
di emergenza che ha un comportamento
responsivo la tenda di emergenza per
situazioni catastrofiche si sono molto
sensibile a questo tema perché comunque
stando nelle marche che studia
università di camerino responsivo
significa che la capacità di modificarsi
di aprile e chiude si grasse a stimoli
che vengono dall'esterno ma quelle che
vi voglio far capire e l'importanza del
disegno all'interno della progettazione
2 parte download da questa esigenza
punto di progettare st tenda pina nostra
risposta naturale i pangolino e bruco
geometra il pangolino quell'animale
molto curioso alla capacità di
arrotolarsi su se stesso con a corato è
molto rigida è un'interessante struttura
da dal punto di vista geometrico fatti
questa estate uno spunto per la parte
esterna e la struttura e bruco geometra
perché ti chiama geometra e che è
preciso al movimento così
incredibilmente geometrico e da questo
mi ha portato a studiare il movimento e
la struttura fino all'analisi geometrica
che partendo da un mondo triangolare
alla sua complessità
questo mi ha portato ad esplorare le
tante discipline geometria design
architettura design per prendermi cura
degli altri e questo è la chiave che ci
porta verso l'innovazione
ma la vera bellezza quale siamo noi e il
nostro cuore e molto spesso non
ascoltiamo il cuore
preferiamo seguire la ragione e io vi
dico
aprite quella porticina e troverete le
risposte che cercate
ma in questo ci può aiutare un'altra
bellezza e silenzio ed è per questo
impallava di al silenzio perché il
silenzio significa stare dentro lo
stesso
è lo specchio della nostra personalità
stiamo vivendo un momento particolare
dove covic e ha isolato da mons
dai familiari amici fidanzati ma non c'è
isolati da noi stessi
ed è proprio questa bellezza che ci dà
la possibilità di prenderci cura di noi
stessi di ascoltare il nostro cuore
quindi impariamo ad apprezzare a
cogliere il silenzio
impariamo a sentire la bellezza ma c'è
più la nostra e dei nostri sogni perché
ragazzi la bellezza è la vera strada che
ci porta verso la ricerca di innovazione
ma soprattutto l'emozione
grazie
[Applauso]